dylan cease goes to the mount forest
fourth time and they've been eerily
similar four two thirds innings each
time three walks each time but last time
out against boston he was throwing more
strikes hopefully that holds up and
dylan cease will face willie calhoun
good change-up for strike three and
dylan cease with the pitch he uses least
gets a strikeout a perfect pitch it was
in the strike zone you see how he splits
his fingers that one just kind of gently
settles away from calhoun
payoff pitch and isaiah shoots that one
out to center field base hit
kinder philippa great about whoa what
happened out there with robert
what in the world and now heading to
third base kenner falefa i didn't get a
real good read on what happened there
and the bases are loaded for texas to
open this series longest inning pitch
wise for dylan sees this year off a
couple days off
for the sox andy busts garcia
fastball hit me he didn't so now here is
nick solac
in the air right hand side adam eaton
makes the catch
so you get the right header dane dunning
as we've talked about going for the
texas rangers look at those numbers
great era the whip the strikeouts the
walks have been fantastic across the
board strikes out swinging
to start the first eaton hitting 262
three homers 14 rbis he's back for his
second tour of duty with the sox right
down the middle strike three called and
eaton
a strikeout victim two away that brings
up jose abreu and he hits this one on
the ground a short stop and counter
falafel will go the short way to retire
montana
jose trevino
one two
it's a fastball and dylan snares it nice
play
two down
he got a fast ball in the zone and
to the glove side not a difficult play
there it is
here it comes
and there he goes
grand all at second mercedes at first so
not a lot of speed aboard double play
would get dane out of the inning here's
the 01 pitch and there's a ground ball
hit on the left side connor for left has
got it to second for one to first
in time they got the double play six
four three
and opposing batters now
with men in scoring position against
dane dunning have gone 049 this year
here's gallow who walked in the first
inning
trouble
and he just took a call third
so cease
as his fourth strikeout and back to back
one two threes sox have two on and
cooking here in the third madrigal at
third
ta at second and three and one from dane
dunning
adam slugs it to left center field
tavares back
and this is down up on the wall
it's a two-run double
for adam eaton and the sox take a
two-nothing lead
this is a fastball it's about thigh high
and out away from adam so it's going to
be one run for sure
but tavares can't get to it garcia can't
get to it
one hop over the wall johann mcconnell
sucks with the lead
that's a laser to first
shallow right and here comes eaton he'll
score easily it's three nothing
that ball
was a missile
to third robert to second you're mean
right side oh my goodness
he just flicked it out there and he gets
two runs out of it
he's just a joy every time he's up there
luis robert with his speed decides to
put gallo to the test and joey gallo
with a very strong very accurate arm
comes in second on this one solac hole
for one
[Applause]
there's a fast ball that ball slug high
in the air deep out to left field it is
gone
so nick solac continues to dominate high
velocity a two-run armor puts the
rangers back in it and 95
plus right on right and nick solak right
on
[Applause]
and wound up just like that in center
field that'll happen to you tim's two
for three
the way he infuses energy into this
offense continues to be on his play when
he's in the line
monkana right side that's a base knock
tim to third he's not going to stop
there and joan
has driven in a couple he's on base all
three times and that is really good news
for the home team six to two
he goes inside out very jose brewish
this is a cutter inside that doesn't get
inside and through the vacated right
side
he drives home another run
nate lowe has walked both times
this has popped up
low was very nice to the kids with what
he said as they're in left is vaughan
reaching back
and andrew vaughan with a tough catch
and then he rolls it to home to keep the
runner at third calhoun
it's going to be up to adolesce garcia
now it's this ball hard
out to left center that one's carrying
well it's gone
garcia with a blast right into the
bleacher seats and left and that got out
in a hurry a three-run shot and just
like that the rangers are within a run
it's 95 miles an hour middle in stark's
middle runs in does a great job getting
the barrel to it i think he knew it
beautiful looking swing there from
adolescence garcia oh now connor falefa
could tie this game if he could find
paydirt let's say the outfield strike
offering and this one bounced right side
base hit that ties the game
trevino touches home
calhoun stops at second and we're square
at six apiece a three-hit night for
connor falefa
two on for joey gallo
brook is bad
on the ground
tim
just handled it in time nearly two had a
chance to turn one here
madrigal double play coming there it is
man oh man the sox'll take that
so one out mercedes robert at second
mercedes right center field tavares
won't get there a four hit night and a
white sox lead all at the same time from
mercedes
yermine just cranks this one the shallow
center field on this slider allows a two
base hitting the go ahead run and now
with a runner at third that you'd love
to play madrigal comes up
first base scorch
stop in the bag is low and the sox get a
run coming home to the back side with
mercedes second and third the tying runs
at second base high fastball will get it
done
there she is strike three
good call that's the first big out that
he has to get and now the man who's
hitting it better than anybody on this
team is coming up next
he busted him with more heat take a bite
out of the rangers liam hendricks
montana the batter two hits three
reaches two knocked in
center field
there's the first home run tonight for
the sox
three for four but you won one gotta
those are three run lead with three outs
to go
william hendricks needs three outs three
and two
struck him out
fastball bottom of the zone
12 strikeouts for the rangers tonight
strike three called in the basement
tougan
hung one a little bit and garcia hits it
a ton deep out to left gone
adali's garcia
he's done it again el bumby
second home run of the ball game a
cannon shot on his mind one and two
three ties
sox win
9-7
[Applause]